tout commence le 11 janvier 2013 sur
demande du gouvernement malien
la france lance l'opération serval
composé de 1700 soldats
la mission est prévue pour être limitée
dans le temps et l'espace et l'objectif
est clair arrêter l'avancée des forces
djihadistes qui avance sur bamako et
permettre aux malices de rétablir sa
souveraineté sur son territoire le mali
fait face à une agression d'éléments
terroristes venant du nord dont le monde
entier c'est désormais la brutalité et
le fanatisme
sauf que la menace djihadiste gagne du
terrain dans le sahel
l'opération barkan prend le relais le
1er août 2014 pour appuyer dans leur
lutte antiterroriste les pays du g5
celle composée du mali donc du burkina
faso du niger du tchad et de la
mauritanie
le budget alloué est de 700 millions
d'euros par an le dispositif est composé
de 5100 militaire trois drones
cet avion de chasse 22 hélicoptères et
près d'un millier de véhicules lourds
légers et logistique
alors oui l'opération barkan a remporté
plusieurs victoires tactiques au sahel
plus d'un millier de djihadistes ont été
neutralisés en six ans mais loin d'avoir
reculé
la menace djihadiste c'est au contraire
étant du résultat pour certains il est
urgent de réduire voire de retirer les
troupes françaises mobilisées sur le
terrain
après cette année malgré nos grands
succès tactique
la situation n'évolue pas favorablement
sur place nous constatons un bilan lourd
trop lourd et un coût financier
important pour la nation nous avons
besoin d'un débat à l'assemblée pour
délimiter quelles sont nos objectifs et
quelles sont les conditions à réunir
pour se retirer car oui je vous le dis
nous n'avons pas vocation à rester
durablement installé au mali
il est nécessaire de remplacer peu à peu
les militaires par des forces de
médiation à l'exemple de ce qui avait
été tentée au kosovo ou encore au rwanda
avec les sociétés civiles et en lien
avec l'union africaine sur place les
attaques terroristes se poursuivre
à cela s'ajoutent des conflits
intercommunautaires meurtriers situation
d'autant plus dégradés qu'un sentiment
anti-français émergent est désormais au
sein des populations locales
lorsqu'il ya eu les otages français au
bénin la force française est intervenue
rapidement
mais quand un village malien est
attaquée et que pendant toute une nuit
et une demi-journée personne
n'intervient on se dit qu il y a un
poids et deux mesures
nous ne connaissons pas toutes les
ficelles politique qu'il ya autour de ça
mais nous le citoyen lambda de la rue
nous ne comprenons pas une présence
française au sahel de plus en plus
discutée emmanuel macron un visite au
niger l'an dernier semble en avoir pris
conscience et prends acte je ne peux pas
accepter d'envoyer nos soldats sur le
terrain dans des pays où cette demande
n'est pas clairement assumée nous sommes
à un tournant de cette guerre